the first question getting right to
business is a question that comes up
all the time when it comes to looking at
research on hypertrophy
and just practical programming by the
way the question comes from
chuck the one-eyed dog what is the best
way to calculate volume for hypertrophy
training
hard sets regardless of reps reps times
weight times
sets question mark yeah so
um this has been a topic of a fair
amount of
debate so the traditional way to
calculate volume for normalizing
programs within the literature has been
to use the volume load
which is sets times reps times weight
multiply those together it gives you
your tonnage
um you know nice happy number in pounds
and kilograms
it feels very scientific because you're
calculating something
um and that's what was used
pretty much exclusively in the
literature to
normalize training programs or into
equate them
for decades like at least two or three
decades
and as best i can tell
someone just started doing that and
everyone else followed suit
um there wasn't a rigorous
process leading up to that to make sure
that that was
actually the best way to equate training
volume
uh assuming you're interested in you
know something that will theoretically
equate outcomes as well
that was just a convention and so that's
what everyone did
um tons of people still calculate their
tonnage as
if it actually means something uh
however
when we look at the research we see
a whole whole lot of instances where
tonnage is different the number of
sets performed is the same and
hypertrophy is the same
so most of those studies are comparing
kind of normal moderate rep moderate
load training to
low load training so for example doing
sets of
eight to ten reps per set with about
seventy seventy five percent of one rep
max
to doing uh sets of you know
20 to 35 reps per set with
below 50 one rep max in
virtually all of the studies that have
used that kind of experimental setup
and have equated the number of sets
performed you see very very similar
hypertrophy but much higher volume loads
with the low load training condition so
it seems like
the number of hard sets is a better way
to
equate training if you're interested in
hypertrophy outcomes
um so
another thing i'll just generally note
is that
even if you kind of hue to the
traditionalist idea of the classic
hypertrophy range of eight to 12 reps
per set
even there like volume loads are going
to be way higher if you're doing sets of
12 versus sets of eight
it's probably gonna be 30 40 higher give
or take
so like ultimately
i don't know what you are measuring
besides tonnage like it gives you
something to calculate but
is it worth calculating something that
doesn't ultimately mean
anything uh with regards to the training
outcomes you're interested in
so just to nuance this a little bit um
when you equate the number of hard sets
pretty close to failure or two failure
that are performed
seems like hypertrophy is pretty similar
but there's
there's ends to that range so for really
really low rep stuff so
here probably thinking triples and below
you probably need to do more sets to get
similar hypertrophic outcomes to
higher rep training and if the load gets
below about thirty percent of one rep
max it seems like
hypertrophy on a per set basis starts
dropping off as well
uh there was a recent study testing that
where they
compare training at i believe
twenty forty sixty and eighty percent of
one rep max
they found similar hypertrophy with
loads between forty and eighty percent
of one rep max but quite a bit
less growth with twenty percent one rep
max so
so there are edges to that range but
probably for sets of between i don't
know maybe
four and forty or fifty reps
it seems like if you're doing the same
number of sets hypertrophy on a per set
basis is pretty similar
if you get too heavy so probably you
know
85 to 90ish percent plus
like heavy doubles and triples
hypertrophy drops off
if you get below 30 one rep max i don't
know why you ever would
unless you're a subject in one of these
studies but uh
but if that happens probably a little
bit lower hypertrophy per set but
through the range where most people
train in hardset seems to be
the way to go so that is
if we're interested in hypertrophy
i think can i make a quick comment on
that yeah you mentioned like
you don't know why somebody would go
below 30. when the first
when there's first a lot of like lively
discussion about the studies showing
like 30
1rm resulting in a decent amount of
hypertrophy
even with that i'm like people were
acting like it was some kind of hack
like oh sweet you can only lift with 30
i'm like who wants to do that man like
yeah that's not a fun way to train at
all
i mean i could see doing it for
like curls or tricep extensions or
something
if you're just going if you're kind of
masochistic
and you're going for a ridiculous pump
and to be
in a reasonable amount of localized
agony for a very long period of time
sure
but doing that for like squats or
deadlifts
[ __ ] that i i was at a conference once
and somebody was
sharing their results on one of those
types of studies and they mentioned that
doing bicep curls with 30 one rep max
uh one of their participants developed
rhabdomyolysis
doing bicep curls what and i believe
they actually
ended up publishing a case report on
that subject that's wild but like can
you imagine
how intense that set of curls was man
that's a more intense set of curls than
i have personally ever experienced
yeah me too um so the one thing i will
say
in favor of volume load is that it
it's probably pretty good if you're
trying to
predict the metabolic cost of training
so one thing that we know is
caloric expenditure scales with work
performed so work here in
in the physics sense and
i mean unless you have a lab setup the
best proxy you're probably going to get
for that is volume load
so i think that that worrying about
volume load if you're specifically
trying to
improve work capacity so just purely the
ability to
do work in a session and recover between
sets
i think volume loads probably a pretty
useful metric then
or if for whatever reason you're trying
to maximize caloric expenditure
during a training session uh volume
loads probably a pretty decent metric
then
but for just purely
interest in hypertrophy number of hard
sets seems to be the way to go
for for most most circumstances